European lawmakers in Strasbourg stood
and applauded Denis mukwege the
Congolese doctor specializes in treating
survivors of rape and other sexual
violence the sakharov prize is awarded
by the European Parliament it's
President Martin Schulz explained why
the house chose to honor mcguigan see
omnes life wouldn't say league of you
have helped reduce the suffering of
countless women and girls you have
provided a refuge for them and offered
them a helping hand to treat their
physical and emotional wounds una
meeting on Zee are never tire of
denouncing the use of systematic rape of
innocent women as a weapon of war mcquay
JS said Europe could help his country
and others to create a political
landscape where people can trust in the
rule of law to protect them from
violence supreme women decision because
the prize is significant if the European
Parliament and the EU member-states help
us in our quest for democracy justice
and development sure she did a democracy
if they don't do that this prize is
practically meaningless Cipriano Appa
beaucoup de significant dennis moco aj's
fight for women's rights and human
rights in general have made him a hero
among Congolese people some were in the
spectators gallery clearly pleased to
see their hero honored